this is a photo here of my grandfather
and my uncle's on what's called
it's a log boom in what was called this
kukum chuck narrows on the shoeshop
river they were regularly crushed in
these logging
adventures and they would have to break
up these log jams with dynamite they
would lose their hands their fingers
almost all of my uncles and grandfathers
and great uncles
had missing fingers it was pretty
exciting way to grow up
and so i actually followed in my
grandfather's footsteps when i was
in my teens you know if girls weren't
actually
allowed to go into forestry we were um
you know we were supposed to go into
nursing or education or something
and so um it was kind of an unusual
pathway for me and i was really
lucky at the time that that ubc where
where i went to university
had just opened its doors to girls and i
was able to start out
doing forestry and this is me when i'm
in my early 20s working for a logging
company so that would have been in the
late 70s and then the early 80s
the whole logging practices had shifted
and they shifted from this
small scale horse logging family
operations to big industrial clear
cutting
and so that's how i started out my
careers is looking at big industrial
clear cutting which was so different
than what how i'd grown up
and right now in british columbia we're
really grappling with
the fact that we only have three percent
of our iconic old growth rainforest
left going back to my own neighborhood
my own where i grew up this is the shoe
shop river where my grandparents
the smart family had homesteaded but it
had become a place of clear cutting as
well and that you can imagine the impact
that would have had
and the changes are cumulative and we're
seeing that signature on the landscape
now this is an is actually a picture
taken about 15 years ago
of what our landscape looks like so i
grew up in a landscape of old growth
forests
british columbia western canada is and i
would say of the west of
of the united states as well has shifted
from a landscape of
old growth forests to a landscape of
clear cuts
with only small pockets of old growth
forests that are left
there are huge implications for that
we've converted these old growth forests
to plantations
and this is what these plantations look
like clear cutting means taking away all
of the trees
and then they're replanted to one or two
species
in this case douglas fir this is a
monoculture meaning one species
and then they're cultivated or weeded
and tended to get rid of all the other
or as many of the other plants as
possible to favor
these trees with the idea being that if
you get rid of the native plants
then all those resources will be
available to grow big fat trees